AIR DOLLY HILL HELLO HERE'S
INNER. EAR OF DOLLY HERE. AB
DINNER. STERN LIKE OWSKI BY
CASKEY HERE. OKAY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE AUTHOR. ITEM WE
MADE YOU. I'M I'M SINGLE
SOMEWHERE ELSE TOO SO YEAH I'VE
CENTER CASKET. MR TERRIFIED I
KNOW WE'RE ON A SHORT TIME
PERIOD I JUST WANTED TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF MY CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE IN THE RECYCLING
AREA IN THE MY DESIRE TO SEE
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM. IN I SEE
THIS THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY IS FIX IS A SMALL PORTION
AND I OF THE PROBLEM AND I
DON'T WANT THE COMMITTEE TO
LOSE SIGHT OF OR ADVOCATES TO
BE HERE TO SAY WE TOOK CARE OF
OUR PROBLEMS AND RECYCLING
AROUND. IT WITH THIS SMALL
LITTLE FILL IN AND LOSE AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE TO
ACTUALLY TAKE CARE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE MEAN I
DON'T KNOW. ABOUT THE CAUGHT
ROUTE BECAUSE EVERY PLANET
WHICH TALKED ABOUT THE PRICE OF
RECYCLABLES I DON'T KNOW THE
BUSINESS MODELS THEY GREW TOO
BIG WHAT WHATEVER THE PROBLEM
IS BUT BUT I WOULD HATE TO SEE
US THINK THAT. OKAY HERE'S A
BANDAID. ON THIS ON THIS
PROBLEM AND THEN NOT DO THE
HARD WORK. IN THE FALL AND NEXT
YEAR TO REALLY DIG IN AND MAKE
A CHANGE FOR THE THAT THIS THE
STATUS QUO SO I KNOW IT'S IN
THE SESSION. AND I KNOW THAT
THESE THINGS COME UP AND I'M
SURE. THE PILOT PROGRAM IN SAN
FRANCISCO IS DELIGHTED THAT WE
HAVE A CHAMPION HERE BUT BUT-
WE REALLY NEED TO. TO SPEND
SOME TIME AND LOOK AT THIS THE
DYSFUNCTION OF THE OF THE OF
THE SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW ACCESS WITH. I KNOW WE HAVE
THE WAY TO THE AUTHOR BUT I
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE I MEAN AS
YOU KNOW THIS OBVIOUSLY. IS
JUST PUSHES ONE EXEMPTION
THIRTY JULY FIRST. I ANOTHER
ONE TO THE PROGRAM FOR
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS OF REALLY
IS A BANDAID I KNOW THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IS THAT IT IS
REALLY YOU COMMIT WORKING WITH
YOU STAKEHOLDERS OVER THE
INTERNET OF COURSE. I ALSO
THINK MORE BROADLY SPEAKING.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH IT
FIFTY FOR TEN EIGHTY. THREE
SPEAK TO. ON THE BROADER LONG
TERM. INTEREST IS HERE WITH THE
SPACE SO. HI BUT I CAN READ THE
MORE I WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS I KNOW THAT
IT'S FINALLY IS ACTUALLY REACH
THE TENSION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IT. WITH
A NEW LEVEL OF URGENCY. THAT'S
IMPORTANT. SO DO YOU WANT TO
LOOK. DO YOU WANNA COME UP AND
QUICKLY. WE GIVE THE- GIVE THE
DETAILS I MEAN WE'VE GOT.
SEVERAL FOLKS. THERE EVERY
SEVEN KIND OF JOHN FAMILIAR
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE WITH
THINGS BILL YEAH. I'M MUCH JUST
COME UP AND GIVE US LIKE A VERY
BRIEF INTRODUCTION. OKAY. OKAY.
ARE THERE YOU GO OKAY I KNOW.
YEAH HE WAS REALLY NERVOUS.
HUMANS YOU HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIDAY SO I WAS I WAS.
AND I CAUCUS MEETING GOING
WHERE YOU DON'T EVEN GOING OVER
THE FALLEN DIES. AB FIFTY FOUR
IS A RESPONSE TO WHAT HAS BEEN
A RECYCLING CRISIS IN OUR STATE
OBVIOUSLY WE HAD RE PLANET
CLOSE OVER TWO HUNDRED
LOCATIONS. THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT WE TALKED WITH THE SENATE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT WE
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL HELP. POTENTIALLY BE A
SHORT TERM FIX BUT WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED A LONGER TERM FIX THOSE
THREE THINGS WITH FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR RECYCLING CENTERS.
FIVE MILLION FOR MOBILE
RECYCLING WHICH WE THINK WE
WANT TO KIND OF FURTHER TRY OUT
AS A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE
RECYCLING AS WELL AS I'M
GETTING RELIEF CALL THE
CONVENIENCE AND GROCERY STORES
AND KIND WIDENING THAT
CONVENIENCE OUT. SO ON WE THINK
THIS IS A GOOD SHORT TERM FIX
TO HELP GET US INTO NEXT YEAR
WITH THE HOPE THAT NEXT YEAR.
WE'LL BE BACK WITH SOMETHING
BIGGER SO WITH THAT HAPPY DICK
QUESTIONS. GOOD THANK YOU YES
SIR WELCOME BACK THANKS SO MUCH
AIR MARIN ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY GROSSES ASSOCIATION.
BANK MISTER TAKING ATTENDANCE
STAFF ASSEMBLY STAFF WORKING ON
THIS PROJECT WE BELIEVE. THIS
WILL BE HELPFUL IN PROVIDING
SOME RELIEF COME BACK. ON TO A
WORK ON A LARGER FIX THAT WE'VE
ALWAYS SAID THAT WE ARE
AMENABLE TO WANT TO. OF SELF
AGAIN THANK ENERGY SUPPORT
GRANT WE APPRECIATE YOUR CAN DO
ATTITUDE. OKAY YES THIS IS YOUR
MEMBERS AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF
SAFELY ALBERTSON'S WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. AND OTHERS
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
TEMPORARY FIX THANK YOU. THE
SHERMAN MEMBERS POLICY WE HAVE
SITTING COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
SERVICES GO IS IN FACT THE
LIGHTED ABOUT THIS BILL OR
DRIVE VOTE AND AGREED TO
CENTERS COMMENTS ABOUT THERE'S
MORE WORK TO BE DONE. SO THANK
YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TONY
GONZALEZ REPRESENTING TIMER
NORTH AMERICA ONE OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST RECYCLING
COMPANIES NOT IN CALIFORNIA. WE
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS BY SENATOR Y. CASKEY
REGARDING. THE NEED AN
IMPERATIVE TO ENACT A LARGER
REFORM THE PROGRAM NEXT YEAR
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
FOR STEP THANK YOU. GERMAN
MEMBERS MIKE MAD ACCOUNTS OVER
CONSUMER WATCHDOG AND I
COULDN'T SAY IT ANY BETTER THAN
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GOOD WE'VE
HAD DISCUSSIONS ALL OVER THE
YEAR. WE HAD A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY SOLUTION. FOR A MID
CENTURY PROBLEM AND WE
APPRECIATE THE URGENTLY NEEDED
EMERGENCY FUNDS AND THAT THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. AND THIS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU ALL. YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHASE AND I COULD
WITHOUT AUSTIN GILBERT ROADS
AND SPENT ON BEHALF OF RITE AID
ALSO. AND SUSAN COLLINS WITH A
IN A RECYCLING INSTITUTE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT AND NOR IN
OPPOSITION. BUT I DO WANT TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION IT WAS
PROPOSED ABOUT. AT BOTH SHARING
THE NEED FOR COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM AND EXPLAINING THAT NO
THE RE PLANET CLOSURE. AND THAT
HAPPENED RECENTLY WASN'T. I'M
UNUSUAL OR UNPREDICTABLE. AND I
SAY THAT BECAUSE WE DID PREDICT
THESE CLOSURES YEARS AGO AND
WROTE PAPERS IN FACT SHEETS AND
DOCUMENTED THAT THESE WERE
GOING TO HAPPEN I DON'T SAY
THAT BECAUSE I HAVE A CRYSTAL
BALL. I SAY THAT BECAUSE I HAVE
A CALCULATOR. THE THIS PROGRAM
HAS HAD FUNDAMENTAL SHORTFALLS
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEMS WITH
PAYMENT FORMULA FOR REDEMPTION
CENTERS. THAT FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM STILL EXISTS MORE
REDEMPTION CENTERS WILL CLOSE
HOUSING A CUTE SITUATIONS LIKE
WHAT EXISTS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WERE ONLY
SIXTY FOUR REDEMPTION CENTERS
EXIST FOR EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE.
SO SMALL ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS
WON'T BEGIN TO CLOSE THIS WHOLE
REDEMPTION CENTERS HAVE BEEN
UNDERPAID SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND JUST THE INCREASE IN
MINIMUM WAGE COST THEM ANOTHER
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR THAT I'M COVERED BY THE
PAYMENT FORMULA SO I HAVE SOME
FACT SHEETS THAT CAN PROVIDE TO
ALL OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THEY EXPLAINED THE SITUATION
BUT WE DEFINITELY DO NEED
FUNDAMENTAL COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM OF THIS PROGRAM OR WILL
JUST CONTINUE TO TURN THIS INTO
A TAX WHERE PEOPLE CAN'T GET
THERE. TENSION VALUE PACK THANK
YOU. YEP OKAY OF FOLKS HONOREE
OKAY MARK MARIE OF MR REMEMBERS
MARK RUTH CALIFORNIA YES WASTE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT LAST
NIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER MARKETS
REALLY WORK TO. OUR OKAY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS THOUGHTS THROUGH
CASKEY MADE A VERY AB. SOLID
COMMENT BEFORE YOU GOT HERE
SOME REMEMBER THAT I I'M SURE
YOU'D AGREE WITH BUT OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THIS IS
THE MOVE BY I CENTER DOLLY.
ASSEMBLY CASKEY AND WE HAVE AN
EXPLANATION OF THE AMENDMENT
LAST NIGHT THAT I MIGHT HAVE
MISSED THAT IS REMOVED MR
MURRAY. CONSULTING SO IT WAS
DONE THE BILL ORIGINALLY WAS
ONLY FIVE MILLION FROM MOBILE
RECYCLING AND THE GROCERY.
CONVENIENCE STORE RELIEF WE
ADDED FIVE MILLION FOUR
RECYCLING CENTERS. WITH SOME
PALM ON PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS AND MY READ. MY
READING IS THAT CAL RECYCLE CAN
EXPAND UP TO FIVE MILLION IN
EACH OF THE FISCAL YEARS. MY RE
I'M READING FROM. FROM
NINETEEN. TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO CAL RECYCLE AT
TO E TO. FIVE MILLION
THAT'S TOTAL SWITCH YOU'RE
SAYING RIGHT SO IT'S TOOL IT'S
FIVE MILLION FOR THAT. THE
REGULAR CENTERS AND FIVE
MILLION FOR THE MOBILE CENTER
YES THAT'S RIGHT. IN IN THAT
ALSO THIS THE THEN THEY OUGHT
THEN THEY CAN EXPAND UP TO FIVE
MILLION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BEVERAGE CONTAINER. PROGRAM TO
THAT WITH FIFTEEN MILLION. ALL
IN. YEAH WELL MY STATUS QUO
FINEST THERE IS ALREADY IS FIVE
MILLION BE APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
IS AN ADDITIONAL TEN. SO YEAH
WE'RE READY WE'RE JUST FIVE
MILLION IN THIS RESPECT. I
REALIZE PART OF THE FIX HERE IS
THAT THE GROCERY STORES THAT
ARE LOCATED IN AREAS THAT DON'T
HAVE A CENTER THAT HAD BEEN.
CLOSE THEY GET OF WAIVER OR OF
WHATEVER WORD YOU WANT TO USE A
TIME HERE WE DON'T HAVE TO PAY
THE HUNDRED DOLLAR BOUNTY IN
TILL THERE'S AN APPLICATION HAS
BEEN FILED IS BEING PROCESS. I
SEE. IT'S REALLY FOR THE FOR
THE GROCERS HOW DOES THAT HELP
OUT THE PROGRAM. BECAUSE THEY
WOULD THEY WOULD RECEIVE.
ASSEMBLY THEY WOULD RECEIVE
THAT MONEY AND GIVE IT OUT TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE. RECYCLING
TO BRING OTHER THINGS IN THE
PROGRAM LEAVE COMES AND THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS SO. AGAIN WE
KNOW IT'S A SHORT TERM FIX JUST
A TIES OVER INTO NEXT YEAR.
WITH AND WE PURPOSELY DID NOT
WANT TO DO. A LOT MORE MONEY
OR- HAVE. A LONGER TIME FRAME
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO. MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A MORE STRUCTURAL.
REFORM A MORE STRUCTURAL.
PROPOSAL NEXT YEAR BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN WAITING IN THE
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING OUT IN THE BUDGET FOR
THE LAST THREE FOUR YEARS AND
REALLY HAVE NOT MADE VERY MUCH
PROGRESS. SO WE KNOW THAT.
GIVEN THE SITUATION THE TIME
IT'S ACTUALLY RIGHT TO DO THE
STRUCTURAL REFORM THAT MANY
PEOPLE TO TALK ABOUT. I'M WELL
AWARE OF THAT LACK OF PROGRESS
YES LET'S BRING THE OIL LONGER.
THAN FOUR YEARS FOR ME TO ASK
BY THE ONLY INVOLVED. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. OKAY
QUESTION FIVE REMOVED BY SENATE
DOLLY. YEAH SENATE ON. I'LL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO BE ON THE
COMMITTEE TO. WORK ON THIS
ISSUE THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S NEW WE HAD YEAH. WORKED
WITH THE AUTHOR ON ON MANY OF
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES I WORKED
WITH THE THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GORDON WHEN HE WAS WORKING ON
RECYCLING ISSUES WITH THESE ARE
NOT JUST GENERIC TO. SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEMS IN THE COUNTY I LIVE
IN LAST YEAR WITH REDEMPTION
CENTERS AND- IT'S A PROBLEM SO
THE BEER THE CALORIE CYCLE I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT HOW THEY'RE DOING
THEY'RE- RUNNING THE PROG.
THERE'S DOOM'S MEANS COST
SAVING MEASURES THERE THAT WILL
HELP. THAT'S RIGHT AND I ALSO
THINK THERE'S A NUMBER OF
STATUTORY CHALLENGES THAT I
KNOW CENTER GLAZERS TRYING TO
DRESS IN A TO SOME EXTENT YOUR
ADDRESS HERE. THEIR HANDS ARE
TIED ALL SORTS OF WEIRD WAYS AS
WE'VE BEEN DIGGING CARVE ITSELF
DEEPER INTO THIS POLICY AREA.
AND SO WE'RE HOPING THAT. GIVE
US MORE FLEXIBILITY SO THEY CAN
ACTUALLY DO THEIR WORK. ON ANY
OUT. OKAY I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT ON THE
COMMITTEE AND I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD. TOTAL MANDATE A HAVING A
PHONE RECOGNIZES THE MANDATE
IT'S IN PERFECT I JUST IT'S
FRUSTRATING HOW UNABLE WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BE AS A
LEGISLATURE AND AS A GOVERNMENT
TO. MAKE PROGRESS ON THIS AND-
WE ALL HAVE TO TOGETHER DOUBLE
DOWN ON TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
IN THE COMING YEAR. SO I WITH
THAT THE MOST HAS BEEN MADE
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FIFTY
FOR THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLEN HI ALLEN HI BATES. BATES
AYE DALI. DALI AYE HILL. HILL
AYE SKINNER STERN MY CAL
SCHEME. MY CASKEY AYE. OKAY
THAT'S A VALUE ZERO SO I KNOW I
KNOW CENTER STERN ANSWER
SKINNER BOTH HEARING HEARINGS.
SO I I'M GONNA GO. PRESENT AYE
AYE WOODS HOLE THIS OPEN
HOPEFULLY. CAN USE THE CURRENT
OR. OKAY BUT WE HAVE TO VOTE.
WE HAVE THE VOTES IS TRUE. YEAH
YEAH OPPOSITION A TEN THIRTY
CENTER. YEAH. PLANT THE SEED.
HI
. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FIFTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS THE PAST A
PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE AT A
TRAVELING I AM BY TRAVELING
FIVE FIVE ZERO SKINNER.
STANDING SIDE AB FIFTY FOUR AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN STERN AYE
THANK YOU THAT'S A SEVEN ZERO
THIS VOTE IS DONE